et
[Musique]
cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous claire
nouvian bonjour bonjour bienvenue sur ce
plateau vous êtes fondatrice de
l'association bloom qui lutte contre la
destruction de l'océan et la surpêche
vous avez obtenu le prix goldman en 2018
on considère que c'est l'équivalent du
prix nobel en matière d'environnement on
le disait à l'instant celui juin c'est
la journée mondiale de l'océan l'océan
70% de la surface de notre planète est
essentielle à la survie de l'homme de
secret ne serait-ce qu'en production
d'oxygène et de ressources je voudrais
qu'on commence par un constat si vous le
voulez bien ce poumon bleus est en péril
oui on le dit on le redit mais
malheureusement il se passe pas grand
chose vous allez me dire c'est le même
sujet sur d'autres gros enjeux
écologiques on a vraiment toutes les
données aujourd'hui on sait que ça va
mal on sait quelle est la raison de ce
mal profond il ya évidemment la
pollution marine mais les experts de de
l'ipb e s vous savez c'est l'équivalent
pour la biodiversité du giec ont
vraiment dit que la pêche industrielle
était le premier facteur de destruction
de l'océan donc on n'a pas vraiment le
choix que de juguler cette pêche
industrielle qui est massive qui se
déploie surtout l'océan il ya moins de
3% de l'océan qui est protégée
aujourd'hui donc c'est une emprise qui
est totale et qui a des conséquences
vraiment désastreuse pour comme vous
disiez notre notre poumon planétaire
l'océan absorbe au moins un quart de nos
émissions globales de co2 et à réguler
d'un point de vue historique 93 % de nos
excédents de chaleur donc vous voyez
bien que on peut pas se permettre de
perdre ce grand thermostat planétaire
c'est le grand régulateur du climat
et on perd aussi et ça c'est bien ce
qu'il faut comprendre il faut bien lier
la question écologique à la question
sociale parce que les pêches
industrielles sont aussi en train de
mettre en péril les équilibres des
pêches artisanales qui dans la plupart
du monde sont des pêches vivrières alors
on a des pêches industrielles qui capte
la ressource avec des méthodes
désastreuse destructrice pas du tout
sélective qui détruisent et les habitats
marins et la biodiversité et en même
temps les plus loire et la sécurité
alimentaire de bien des peuples autour
de la planète la mère fait vivre un
milliard de personnes directement
aujourd'hui un apport de protéines un
milliard de personnes sur la planète
90% des populations de gros poissons
déjà épuisé 50 % des récifs coralliens
détruit ce sont des chiffres de l'onu ça
c'est ça c'est la conséquence directe de
la pêche industrielle où il y a eu
d'autres d'autres facteurs non vraiment
enfin bien sûr qu'il ya des facteurs
multiples mais entre le changement
climatique les la prédation direct à
destruction directe des écosystèmes par
la pêche industrielle et l'absence de
régulation parce que la plupart de
l'océan se retrouve aussi dans une zone
internationale ou la gouvernance est
très faible et où les industriels ont
fait main basse sur les ressources non
on est vraiment il y a urgence urgence à
comprendre qu'il n'y aura pas de
solution climat sans l'océan et que une
des mesures phares de toussaint c'est
protéger l'océan en grande partie
d'ailleurs pour protéger les pêches
artisanales pour leur donner un espace
où dans la plupart des aires marines
protégées au sens strict les uns toutes
les activités industrielles sont
interdites mais pas la pêche artisanale
donc si on veut aider les pêches
artisanales au niveau mondial et même au
niveau européen vous avez que la
compétition entre les gros et les petits
elle se fait aussi en europe 1 là où on
perd des emplois en france ou en europe
c'est évidemment dans le secteur
artisans donc l'urgence est de protéger
ça c'est vraiment ce qu'il ya de plus
efficace pour restaurer les écosystèmes
pour restaurer la biodiversité et pour
aider le climat et les pêcheurs avant de
revenir sur les sur les solutions si on
ne fait rien le scénario catastrophe
c'est quoi concernant l'océan alors le
scénario gaga sort je peux vous dire
puisque moi j'ai grandi à hong kong et
j'ai vu ce que c'était qu'un scénario
catastrophe ils ont attendu qu'il n'y
ait plus aucun poisson pour interdire
les chalutiers donc le chalutage de fond
observées sur les techniques de pêche
des grands filets qui raclent le fond
qui ne sont pas du tout sélectif qui
détruisent l'environnement marin et donc
sa productivité à terme un bien sûr et
bien à hong kong on a attendu que les
poissons qu'ils étaient capturés dans
les filets soit plus petit qu'une pièce
de deux euros aujourd'hui donc quand ils
en sont arrivés là les pêcheurs se sont
mis à faire en effet du trafic eu à
l'époque hong kong étaient britanniques
ils ont commencé à faire du trafic de
drogue etc et là ils se sont dit bon bah
on va arrêter la pêche mais il y avait
plus rien on a vu tout détruit donc nous
en europe on veut comme dire qu'on a mis
en place on s'est réveillé à temps on a
mis en place des mesures qui permettent
au moins de stabiliser le drame jean
vide on a au moins maintenue les stocks
de poissons très bas mais on a arrêté le
déclin maintenant il va falloir
reconstruire et pour reconstruire il
faut une volonté politique
aujourd'hui les lobbys industriels
malheureusement tiennent vraiment la
plume des législateurs et en
l'occurrence aussi notre président de la
république alors la france possède le
deuxième le deuxième domaine maritime
mondial derrière les etats unis a on le
sait peu 10 millions un peu plus 10
millions de kilomètres carrés est ce
qu'elle est à la hauteur de ces enjeux
je crois que je connais votre réponse
est un non malheureusement est en fait
j'aimerais tellement vous dire le
contraire j'aimerais tellement pouvoir
concentrer mes heures de travail
quotidiennes à autre chose que de me
battre contre mon pays dont le
gouvernement malheureusement nous a
vraiment menti et de façon
intentionnelle vous savez depuis 2019
emmanuel macron répète et est applaudi
il a fixé des objectifs en baisse il a
il répète qu' on va protéger 30% de
notre territoire marin dont 10 % en
protection forte l'union internationale
tant statut particulier la voix lui icn
vous savez l'union internationale pour
la conservation de la nature a bien
clarifiée qu'une aire marine protégée ne
peut être appelé protégés que si elle
interdit toutes les activités
industrielles la pêche des extractions
les installations industrielles donc
quand le président dit on va protéger
30% des territoires marins
applaudissements bravo c'est exactement
ce qu'il nous faut et donc ça veut dire
qu'on interdit toutes les activités
industrielles dans 30% de notre
territoire marin et qu'on permet par
contre la pêche artisanale et quand on
dit que quand il promet qu'on va
protéger 10 % en protection forte ça
veut dire que dans ces zones de 10% il
n'y aura aucun prélèvement humain et
c'est évidemment vous imaginez bien ce
qu'il ya de plus efficace pour restaurer
l'océan les chercheurs ont montré que
dans une zone vraiment parfaitement
protégés sans même de prélèvement
artisanale la biomasse des poissons
étaient 6 170% supérieur au zoo qui
n'était pas protégée donc si on veut
mettre un gros coup de boost ou à la
restauration de la santé de l'océan
c'est dans des zones intégralement
protégée et bien ce que le président a
fait alors qu'il préparait son discours
de marseille vous savez le 16 avril dans
l'antre de taux il a parlé planification
écologique pour ramener l'électorat très
hésitant l'écologiste et bien le 12
avril un décret gouvernemental était
signée qui détruisait la notion de
protection en fait protégé ça doit
vouloir dire sauvegarder mettre à l'abri
et c'est préserver et bien là ça veut
dire exploiter parce que dans le décret
du 12 avril que nous aujourd'hui nous
nous engageons une procédure formelle
nous en un recours contre ce décret
parce que ce décret dit qu'en fait on va
on n'aura pas des repas ring protéger il
n'y aura pas d'aires marines protégées
c'est un gruyère avec des énormes trous
qui sont prévus pour laisser passer les
activités industrielles dans toutes les
aires marines protégées y compris dans
les zones qui sont supposés être
parfaitement sens que tu as he is et
c'est un danger je ne serai pas insister
assez pour me dire à quel point ce
danger est majeur parce que comme vous
le disiez la france est le deuxième
territoire marin au niveau mondial donc
c'est un impact direct sur le sien mais
vous imaginez bien que la france qui est
donc la première puissance maritime au
niveau européen si la france définit à
sa sauce la notion de protection mais
alors ça veut dire qu'on va niveler vers
le bas déjà toute la protection au
niveau français mais aussi au niveau
européen et international
c'est vrai c'est calamiteux c'est c'est
pour ça que bloom se mobilisent les
attaques ce décret donc pour essayer de
simplifier vous accuser le gouvernement
de ne pas participer à la protection de
zones importantes qui devraient être
interdites à la pêche industrielle je
fais simple d'aucuns pourraient vous
dire que de cette pêche dépendent des
emplois des familles
mais alors déjà je l'aurais de la
construction sociale j accuse enfin nous
accusons avec bloom puis des citoyens le
gouvernement non seulement d'avoir menti
sur la protection il fallait pas
protégés et dire qu'on allait protéger
30% de notre territoire ainsi en fait on
avait l'intention de laisser passer
toutes les activités industrielles et
plus impactante mais on les accuse aussi
d'intentionnalité cirque un mensonge
dans tout ça à partir de 2019 avoir
répété à l'envi avoir reçu des titres de
champions de la terre de la mer et que
sais-je pour avoir en fait
instrumentalisés et avoir une
intentionnalité d'escroquerie parce
qu'en fait il a bien attendu le
lendemain du premier tour pour signer ce
décret vous comprenez donc on est resté
dans ce flou pendant toutes ces années
tout le monde bravo pourquoi parce que
il y a une définition très claire de ce
que ça veut dire protéger parce que lui
hissène a dit protégé c'est pas
d'activités industrielles donc c'est
vraiment acquis en belgique donc c'est
plus grave que juste dire vous fait pas
le job et c'est pas bien c'est de dire
il y à une intentionnalité c'est une
forme d'escroquerie d'avoir promis
quelque chose en ayant organisé
vous savez au moment du wan ho shon
schmitt emmanuel macron avant les
élections présidentielles à organiser un
sommet à brest cet hiver et voilà il a
annoncé le 11 février on va protéger on
l'a tout va bien on augmente la part de
deux zones qui sont sous protection
forte alors qu'en fait depuis une
semaine le décret qui redéfinissait sk
vers l'âme à la baisse ce que ça veut
dire de protéger fortement étaient déjà
préparés d'envoyer ses maquis avait dit
que ça ça se fait pas ça ça ne se fait
pas parce que ça c'est un mensonge mais
aussi quand les industriels disent nous
ce sont des emplois si vous enlevez la
pêche industrielle des zones protégées
d'abord c'est irresponsable d'un point
de vue climatique il se trouve que les
pêches industrielles ce sont les plus
impactante d'un point de vue climat et
elle n'existerait pas sans les
subventions publiques c'est bien ce
qu'il faut se dire c'est que vos impôts
mes impôts permettent à la pêche
logiciel d'exister en fait elle est la
pêche industrielle ce sont des engins
qui sont lourds qui sont tractés pour
attraper le premier poisson et ça a
besoin de beaucoup de gasoil donc alors
je vous dis pas qu'en ce moment
évidemment avec l'augmentation des prix
du baril ont cependant une espèce de de
dépendance structurelle qui finit par
peser si lourd dans le chiffre
d'affaires que l'on rajoute des aides
publiques mais donc sans être publique
cette pêche elles restent à quai donc en
fait aujourd'hui entre des écosystèmes
qui sont fragiles qui ont besoin elles
protégées de la pêche artisanale qui est
déjà une solution d'avenir qui a déjà
inventé ce que c'est que la pêche
durable faut pas chercher midi à
quatorze à avoir des mythiques ce qu'on
appelle des engins à faible impact ça
existe il suffit d' encourager tout ça
et ça demande de la volonté politique et
donc de se libérer d'un lobby breton
incarner quand même par jean yves le
drian depuis très longtemps de richard
ferrand etc à propos de volonté
politique en quelques mots on a quelques
jours des élections législatives votre
association bloom a fait circuler une
charte océan auprès des candidats en
quelques mots parce que le temps nous
manque que contient tel et par qui at
elle été signé alors la charnie la
charte pour l'océan de blum à 10 points
prioritaires qui permettrait de sortir
de la voie de garage dans laquelle on
s'est mises qui est une voix absolument
catastrophique de destruction des
emplois des finances publiques et de
l'écosystème et donc zéro solution
climat et l a été pour l'instant
endosser massivement par la france
insoumise e élevé évidemment et
00 engagement du côté évidemment de la
majorité présidentielle l'appel est
lancé merci beaucoup merci aux clients
d'être venu ce matin assure plateau de
paris direct et donc on peut retrouver
vos travaux bien sûr sur le site de
l'association bloom qui luttent donc on
l'a compris contre la destruction de
l'océan et la pêche industrielle à
l'occasion donc de ce 8 juin journée
mondiale pour les océans ou l'océan tout
court merci encore bonne journée à vous
alors